the vengers endgame has officially been
released it's crushing the box-office
shattering records just demolishing and
I'm hoping the majority of you have seen
it I wanted to give you guys enough time
to see the movie before I talked
spoilers so that's your warning this is
going to be a spoiler filled review
before I get any farther than review I
have to do something very special
now that you've been warned we can talk
about spoilers I can finally talk about
this movie now I can actually like say
things fully completely without worrying
about spoilers first off I want to make
an amendment I made an error in my
original review the Russo brothers did
not write the film as well as direct
that's my fault
they directed the film the script was
written by Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely and they did an
excellent job
I apologize for that's my bad but I
mentioned in my review that I had
something that I predicted that I was
thinking it might go a certain way most
of my friends were saying they're gonna
use the time stone to reverse time and
blah blah blah and that's like kind of
where everyone was gravitating towards
but I was pretty sure that we're gonna
try to do time travel and jump back and
forth between other films we had seen
before in the past ten years and loop
all of them into this big arc and that's
exactly what they did and I said in my
review I wasn't like disappointed by
that
I wanted that to happen I love the idea
of Captain America and Tony and all of
them encountering their past selves
looking back on things they did maybe
some things that they weren't too happy
about and they had to comment on them
the Americas ass joke was great I loved
how that played throughout the scene but
it does take a while to set up the rules
of what they're going for and you kind
of just have to sit back and accept it
all right Tony Stark's a genius Bruce
banners of genius they're all geniuses
in different ways okay they did it they
got time-travel alright they'll fucking
figure it out I guess you just kind of
have to accept it and just move on with
it otherwise you're gonna be sitting
there nitpicking that's what I talked
about the most when I refer to
nitpicking in my original review it's
super easy to nitpick time-travel movies
and different films as mentioned in this
movie have presented it in various ways
where if you go back and change
something it means the future gets
changed but this film takes the idea of
that creates a brain
it's reality like an alternate reality
when you change it and and so it's a
little confusing to really think about
what's going on in the first act and you
can really nitpick at hardcore or you
can just enjoy the experience because
the Russo brothers made a damn good
movie
I expected that us to be out of the
picture somehow because he was barely in
a trailer and I found that odd and so I
wasn't that surprised that they murder
him right off the bat I loved Thor's
line I went for the head going back to
infinity war I really liked how that all
played out and that was sort of the
movie we expected to see but maybe some
people thought that would happen more
towards the end sort of like the
beginning of glass the first like 20
minutes of glass was how I thought the
whole movie would be but it was just the
beginning and then we cut to five years
later and that was surprising and I
loved how Steve was part of a self-help
group he was sort of doing like what
Falcon did he was just doing everything
he could to help people even if he
couldn't be Captain America like he used
to be he was just in a self-help group
talking to people about their feelings
and I thought that was really special
when ant-man comes back into play with
information about the quantum realm
things really start to get moving in
regards to the time travel element of
the plot but I got I got Tony back in
there he's got a kid now which is
awesome
that was obviously one of the most
heartfelt aspects of the movie I have
seen so many people talking about that
line I love you 3,000 because it really
is kind of crushing especially when you
see how the film plays out I like what
they did with Hawkeye - they definitely
took him in a direction I didn't really
anticipate tried to stay away from plot
details I knew of the Ronin persona and
like what that meant for him but I just
didn't really know what exactly they
were gonna do with him and I loved the
scene where he's like killing folks in
Tokyo that was awesome and they did a
good job of reminding us why Black Widow
and Hawkeye our friends in this movie
they tried to hit the right emotional
beats leading up to black widows
eventual sacrifice and what that means
for those characters they even reference
Budapest again and let's talk about that
sacrifice for a minute because I kind of
wanted Hawkeye to be the guy to jump and
so when he jumps I was like okay I'm
satisfied but then Black Widow saved him
and I was like damn I get it he's got a
family
he has a wife he has kids I just my
preference is that I've always liked a
black widow character
more than Hawkeye so I would have loved
to have seen her stick around for the
final battle at least but I get that in
the sense of like moral rightness it
makes more sense for Hawkeye to be alive
so he can take care of his kids and
family I just kind of wish that Black
Widow had survived that at the same time
it confuses me because they finally
announced a deal to make a black widow
movie and I'm wondering if that's gonna
still happen it would obviously have to
be a prequel then I would assume I hope
that they finally make a black widow
movie it's one of the films I've been
wanting to see ever since the beginning
of her introduction in Iron Man 2 I've
always wanted a black widow movie and I
hope they still do it I just don't know
what they're gonna do with it now now in
my original review I mentioned that the
film does take risks with its characters
one of them being Thor and I gotta be
honest I fucking loved it for a lot of
reasons Chris Hemsworth he is hilarious
he is a way way better actor than he
gets credit for he is phenomenal but I
kind of loved it for another reason -
he's got this beer belly through the
whole movie he has crushing anxiety and
panic attacks and yet he still dons his
outfit and he fights that house
nevertheless he never uses magic or some
superpowers to get back to his old shape
he just stays that way and he fights
Thanos and stands up for himself and his
friends and I thought that was a good
message you do not have to look like a
maxim model to be a hero I like that
it's cool another risk that could
potentially put off people was what they
did with Hulk in this film they've now
sort of merged him into the professor a
smarter version in which Banner and Hulk
have sort of combined to just exist I
loved it I mean why not they have
continuously done different things with
the Hulk to make sure he doesn't get
stale because that's the biggest danger
with that character he's a fan favorite
for a reason but if he just shows up and
smashes things in every movie it
wouldn't really be that cool after a
while but they have always tried to take
him in a different direction
Ragnarok they finally had him talk and
he was in this weird planet and he was
happy being there and it was just really
funny he disappeared for a while after
all
Tron and now he's back with this new
thing and an infinity war he barely
showed up at all so they've tried to do
their best to make that character stay
fresh and I love the idea that banner
being as smart as he is would figure
this out finally finally accept what's
inside of him for what it is and just
learn to live with it and really I just
have to give it to the entire creative
team behind the MCU for crafting this
world for as long as they have because
as we got towards that final battle with
past Thanos realizing you know what this
doesn't have to happen anymore
clearly my my life dream is it's not
worth anything because the people who
are left over they're always gonna miss
what they had and not accept what they
have and so we get the big final battle
they did get the Infinity stones and
were able to bring everybody back and I
have to give such props to the creative
team because I just didn't realize how
emotionally invested I was in it this
movie has something that a lot of Marvel
movies don't have and it's actually a
feeling of finality you feel like you
were experiencing something ending and
like this is really something to pay
attention to and I felt invested and my
god I mean let's talk about Tony Stark
um so I definitely cried and when I say
I cried I didn't I didn't like tear up I
was full-on
bottom lip quivering just the little
jittery shaking just I really felt it
for this character and Downey jr. I've
seen a lot of campaigning for him to get
an Oscar nomination for this movie and I
would totally be behind that who cares
if he's wearing a CGI suit or something
like his performance is excellent he's
really great in this movie and the idea
of his final words being the words that
ended the first Iron Man film that's
also just a gorgeous idea I thought it
was wonderful oh my god yes I forgot
about Captain America with Thor's hammer
you see that right there is every movie
has like that one moment where you're
like fuck yes and that was this movie's
moment for me it that was just great you
know it harken back to Ultron where it
were Steve budged the hammer and Thor
cut that looked like what oh shit that
whole sequence was just pure fan
happiness it gave me what I needed it
made
you feel fulfilled made me happy made me
excited but after Tony died his funeral
like I was already feeling it when he
gave the message to his family and then
when you see the flowers floating and
but the next shot where it pans across
like everyone he's impacted over these
years even the kid from Iron Man 3 ty
Simpkins I lost it I mean I lost it I
saw it at a press screening and then my
wife and I went to a drive-in theater
actually there's a drive-in still near
us in Ohio and I saw it a second time at
the drive-in and we're in the car and
the windows are fogging up because we're
just bawling our eyes out like I can
hear my wife she's like crying like
she's lost every a loved one that's how
well these guys crafted this universe
and you just have to give it to them
despite what nitpicks you could have
with each little film and and some of
the other Marvel films that aren't
really that great you just have to sit
back and really give them a round of
applause for crafting such a unique
universe that is filled with so many
amazing characters and it's not really
until you see that arc that you can
actually sit back and think man they
really did something unprecedented and
this is probably not gonna happen for a
long time so after that funeral Captain
America has got to go try to hide the
Infinity stones and he goes away for a
long time he doesn't come back in the
machine like they think he's going to
and he shows up as this old man and you
realize he's lived an entire life up
until now and he looks extremely
fulfilled and happy
he gives the the shield to sam falcon
one of my friends was hoping it was
Bucky I'm actually really glad at Sam
yeah he has more of an emotional
connection with Bucky but let's just say
the MCU was real life okay and Captain
America was legitimately Captain America
in real life soldier you know and we got
this Winter Soldier guy who was like a
terrorist for a while like shooting up
public streets and buses and trying to
murder people doesn't really make sense
to me to give that person the shield
even though it was mind control and
everything it's like the general public
persona would be like why is he captain
erricka like that's a terrorist you know
Sam's been by cap side this whole time
he's never missed a step I like that I
really thought that was cool
and the final scene with Rodgers and
Carter dancing that was emotionally
satisfying just about everything I
wanted to see happen the way I wanted to
see it and some of the extra things I
got I was fine with and like I said in
my original review I think one of the
best parts of this movie is that the
superheroes here feel more human than
they ever have before they feel
desperate they feel like they've got
something to lose and they have lost so
honestly this movie gave me just about
everything I wanted I had little minor
nitpicks here and there but I did enjoy
it more the second time just like I did
with infinity war there's probably some
things I forgot to mention and the O
Stanley's final cameo and that was sad
too it was nice to see him though but
there's probably a few things I forgot
to mention but overall those are my
in-depth thoughts on in-game I hope you
guys enjoyed it to let me know what you
thought of the film down below and as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you